je vais faire l'interview mais je trouve
dans cet hymne des mouches pas ce que
vous en pensez je trouve que ça va pas
il manque un truc donc introduit ce
qu'on peut appeler josé s'il vous plaît
josé mon ami josé super oc c merci merci
merci
cros et dimanche quelque chose sur cette
interview can we are in ou bien à
l'époque vous saviez déjà vous voulez
faire de la télé on faisait de la radio
j'ai ça va être joué et de journalistes
je sais pas je voulais faire de la télé
mais je suis super heureux de voir rossé
bien essaye de suivre le rythme parce
qu'on a un sujet dimanche sur le mexique
ah bah voilà sous celle appris que vous
êtes à 8 bien sur wii
en parallèle vous débutez la céder à la
télévision sur la chaîne météo vous êtes
chaîne météo à la bad ouais ouais mais
mes premiers pas devant une caméra
c'était effectivement la chaîne météo
que je faisais en tant que pigiste alors
que j'étais à france info
grâce à mon ami bernard thomasson que je
salue d'ailleurs en 2005 vous êtes
repéré par canal+ allaient commencer
cette belle carrière dans la formation à
la télé avec i télé vous présenter la
grande édition de 18h à 18h30 tout à
fait c'est vraiment des visions mais 18
heures 18 heures qu'on ne sait pas c'est
pour moi qui passait de gens nous fait
minutes la france info c'est
effectivement une grande édition
elles ont profité pour saluer maitena
biraben et qu'est ce que le midi je
faisais le journal dont nous ne sommes
pas des anges est vrai et c'est sur ce
plateau
oui c'était en 2006 je vais devenir une
star de l'information c'est l'ancien
patron tf1 etienne mougeotte qui vous
repère et vous êtes nommé joker de ppda
votre premier jt c'était le 17 juillet
2006 vous aviez fait 8 millions de
téléspectateurs
44 verges lui % de parts de marché
regarde
bonsoir à tous voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce lundi actualité
largement dominée par la situation au
proche orient et frappe israélienne au
liban se sont poursuivies aujourd'hui
alors que deux nouvelles roquettes
tirées par le hezbollah ont frappé le
nord d'israël
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre attention à suivre les prévisions
météo d'evelyne dhéliat et puis ce sera
votre série de l'été le maître du
zodiaque pour la formation en demain ce
sera jacques legros à 13h et j'aurai le
plaisir de vous retrouver à 20h bonne
soirée c'est la première fois que autant
d'image de ce premier jt mais oui
évidemment je m'en souviens et je me
souviens d'une journée très tranquille
et du pic de stress au moment où les
vignes bellia termine sa météo à 19h55
et qu'elle dit le journal dans un
instant le journal par harry roselmack
il me rends compte que c'est bien de
cela qu'il est question et que je vais
devoir en antennes ben ça c'est honteux
c'est énorme et fo le voulait pour la
météo départ ouais c'est fou quoi mais
quelques années auparavant et c'est vrai
que c'est une histoire que je raconte
parfois voilà aux gens qui m'interroge
et je le redis rester vraiment focus sur
ce que vous voulez faire et ne soyez pas
détournées par d'autres propositions
parce que c'est vrai que plusieurs
années je crois qu'il est sain
jersey avant le jt j'avais été approché
de façon très très sympathique par la
direction antennes de tf1 pour
effectivement présenté la météo ce que
j'avais refusé de faire parce que je
voulais faire du journalisme est exquise
ans après je suis revenu
mais un jour alors c'est bien parce que
c'est vous qui avez arrêté c'est vous
qui va arrêter le nom de tristesse deux
pas de ses soeurs et donc la guitare oui
c'est moi qui vous parce que vous êtes
je pense que vous êtes le seul à voir
arrêtez de vous même d'habitude le mec
qui présente le masters il est arrêté et
vous c'est c'est un truc de fou
alors mes sept tamgho a refusé c'est
quand même extrêmement rare chez moi
c'est vrai que j'ai décidé d'arrêter le
jt parce que je faisais beaucoup de
choses par ailleurs et que je
considérais que c'était pas très
équilibré de faire trop de choses de
travailler pendant la saison de
travailler pendant les vacances pendant
les congés des titulaires se jetter
joker et donc je suis allé voir
catherine nayl tettey manière lectrice
de l'info et les formations et et on
avait une très belle relation puisque
c'était elle m'a rédactrice en chef dans
le journal qu'on a l'extrait de la santé
vous voulez partir ou pas avant et elle
a compris en tout cas elle a compris mon
raisonnement qui était qui était très
mûrs et j'ai jamais regretté de devoir
arrêter de faire le journal d'abord
parce qu'il est très bien incarnée par
gilles bouleau et assure même que les
équipes aient eux et parce que moi je
suis sur notre aventure qu on vous a
proposé de remplacer jean pierre pernaut
ou par un instant non jamais non alors
ça vous aurait intéressé au pas du tout
2010 non non et thierry thulliez la
trêve il ya trop de l'info de tf1 on
voit là on a des discussions un peu
informelle en avait parlé de deux
j'avais envie de faire dans l'absolu et
savez que ce n'est pas quelque chose qui
me qui me tentait ça reste une fierté
pour vous d'avoir fait le jt de 20h de
tf1 sur et je croise aller toutes les
semaines et quasiment tous les jours des
gens qui me disent bravo et qui me
disent ce que ça leur a apporté ce
milieu encore schl et chercher un plat à
emporter dans un restaurant dont
mexicain s'y tient ty l'ont enfin ou à
la caisse
il y avait un noir et c'est un beur qui
a lancé sa star en taille
comme quoi il ya plein de belles choses
à la diversité de sites de ce pays et
la personne qui était à la caisse me
disais que voilà il n'était très fier de
ce que j'avais fait et ça sans rien moi
un tout car ils pouvaient être fiers de
vous et moi je trouve excellent à
l'antenne j'ai toujours dit à risque et
pas il te sers je suis j'adore cette a8
mais c'est vraiment l'affairé c'est très
bien produit en plus j'embrasse les
producteurs d'ailleurs voilà j'en vois
se passe est une manuelle
emmanuel chain les insultes les réseaux
et thierry bizot qui m'a fait rentrer en
boîte pendant des années donc jamais et
je l'embrassé guéri et c'est vraiment
une super équipe si ce magazine marche
autant c'est parce que on a de supers
reporter une super rédaction chat sur
andy lally paix de traitement de
l'actualité unique je pense 14 ans que
vous faites c'est m
ouais c'est ma quinzaine aux angles
c'est fou est ce que tf1 vous a proposé
d'autre chose parce que ça c'est triste
mais vrai le alors oui oui oui mais j'ai
fait autre chose
moi j'ai fait un format qui s'appelle en
immersion que premier carton vous étiez
venu me voir
j'avais adoré voilà c'était c'est
vraiment ce qui correspondait le mieux à
ce que j'attends de ce métier de
journaliste habituellement un trait les
gens passer du temps avec eux les
comprendre donc j'ai fait les immersions
que j'ai décidé aussi d'arrêter parce
qu'on était arrivé je pense au bout du
format et est ensuite moi c'est vrai que
j'ai créé ma société de production
on en parlait tout à l'heure avec monde
je ne suis pas passionné par
l'incarnation par le fait d'être à
l'écran c'est une conséquence de ce que
je fais et que j'assume bien sûr effet
mais aujourd'hui je fais plein de choses
je fais de la production c'était
compliqué de cette sphère heures mais
amèrement là j'ai créé un film que j'ai
réalisé près lui et voilà je fais plein
de choses qui me passionnent